a minute silent on the White House lawn
to remember the victims of 911 the u.s.
used the al-qaeda attacks as
justification for wars in Afghanistan
and Iraq
12 years later a majority of Americans
are against involvement in another armed
conflict with that in mind Obama pitched
his address to the nation my fellow
Americans tonight I want to talk to you
America is not the world's policeman
terrible things happen across the globe
and it is beyond our means to right
every wrong but when with modest effort
and risk we can stop children from being
gassed to death and thereby make our own
children safer over the long run I
believe we should act despite this Obama
said he was willing to give diplomacy
another chance but he made clear that a
military strike remained on the table
meanwhile I've ordered our military to
maintain their current posture to keep
the pressure on us up and to be in a
position to respond if diplomacy fails
many suspects Russia's proposal for
Syria to give up its chemical weapons
was simply a plot to my time but it also
provided a face-saving opportunity for
Obama whose plan to strike Syria was
facing a likely defeat in Congress
agreement must verify that